let's talk about Iran I know there was
some talk that perhaps a meeting would
happen between President Trump and Iran
president rouhani rouhani yesterday
before the UN said that president Trump
has tendencies resembling a Nazi
disposition and that America's first
strategy is a symptom of weakness of
intellect how do you sit down with
someone like that well there's not going
to be a meeting president Trump has said
when that when the Iranians are prepared
to talk about fundamentally changing
their behavior than he is of course
prepared to talk to them at the
statements yesterday indicate that
they're not in that place and it is
outrageous for him to say so that you
think for a holocaust denying country
that is threatening Israel to compare
the United States or its leader to Nazis
is among the most outrageous things I
have heard and I will tell you in
diplomacy you hear a lot of them the
most outrageous things I have ever heard
and yet you are ramping up sanctions on
Iran and then the news that Europe China
and Russia are all going to create this
back channel so that they can keep
economic relationships with Iran despite
these US sanctions I mean what does that
say about our relationship with those
countries in the fact that they've
created this back-channel hosted a
dinner with them last night
there are lots of places we're working
with our transatlantic partners in
fundamentally important ways on chemical
weapons lots of places where we have
great overlap they've taken a different
path with respect to the jcpoa that's
been clear for some time here's what I'd
say about their decision yesterday to
continue to create mechanisms to fund
the world's largest state sponsor of
Terror is disastrous policy and I hope
they will reconsider it but most
importantly European businesses are
voting with their checkbooks
they are leaving Iran in droves these
sanctions will be effective they are
effective and come November 4th they'll
be even more effective
isn't it a lot more effective though
when the world enforces the sanctions
than just US sanctions we're going to be
incredibly effective you can see it
today the rial trades it over a hundred
and fifty thousand rehaul to the dollar
the economy is collapsing there are two
reasons for that one is certainly the
pressure that's put in place but most
importantly it's the create total chaos
Korea
by the Islamic Republic arounds
government they treat their people
horribly they spend billions of dollars
committing terror acts around the world
and they don't take care of their people
and you see the protests you see the
anger on the streets of Tehran and in
the rural areas that's a result of
terrible government and the Iranian
people aren't going to stand for it and
the American people are gonna stand with
the Iranian people I know